americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 12.
and welcome to hannity the 45th
president of the united states donald
trump he will join us in a moment but
first it was the single deadliest day
for u.s troops in afghanistan in over a
decade 12 marines one navy medic were
murdered 18 other soldiers seriously
injured and are now being flown out on a
c-17 transport plane with surgical units
that are on board dozens of civilians
also killed including many young
children when two suicide bombers
several isis gunmen launched a terror
attack
at the karzai
kabul international airport now tonight
we pray for all of those that have lost
their lives their families and sadly we
fear that the bloodshed is far from over
before we interview president trump you
will join us tonight we exclusively
obtained it just released moments ago
this message from president trump to you
the american people take a look
as one nation america mourns the loss of
our brave and brilliant american service
members
in a savage and barbaric terrorist
attack in afghanistan
these noble american warriors laid down
their lives in the line of duty
they sacrificed themselves for the
country that they loved racing against
time to rescue their fellow citizens
from harm's way
they died as american heroes and our
nation will honor their memory forever i
want to express my deepest condolences
to the families of those we have lost
today all americans grieve alongside you
together we also pray that god will heal
the other courageous american service
members who were wounded in this heinous
attack
in addition our hearts are with the
families of all the innocent civilians
who died
and with the many men women and children
who were terribly injured in this act of
evil
this tragedy should never have taken
place it should never have happened and
it would not have happened if i were
your president
over the past few weeks i know that many
americans have felt profound sorrow and
even pain
watching the events taking place in
afghanistan
and perhaps none more so than the
veterans of that 20-year war
many of them answered the call proudly
and without hesitation
after the terrorist attacks of september
11 2001.
every american who served in afghanistan
has made tremendous sacrifices for our
country
on behalf of your fellow citizens i want
you to know that those sacrifices were
not made in vain
we know
what you did we know how brave you were
and we thank you we salute you and we
honor you for all time
i hope that every american will join me
in continuing to pray for the safe
return of all u.s citizens and soldiers
from afghanistan in the coming days
thank you
god bless you and god bless america
now the president will join us
momentarily and tonight we are praying
for our brave men and women abroad it is
a difficult position they've been put in
now thanks to joe biden's asinine if you
want to even call it withdrawal strategy
we have one way in and one way out of
afghanist afghanistan that is the
mohammed karzai international airport
how in the hell is any american supposed
to get inside that airport it is now
surrounded completely by the taliban and
they won't let any of our afghan allies
through and now there are multiple
reports that americans can't get through
that they're taking their passports and
getting rid of them and our state
department in the last 24 hours has now
said multiple times to people our
american citizens fellow citizens in
afghanistan to stay away from the
airport which is under constant threat
from terrorists and was just brutally
attacked as you can see on your screen
by isis
would you want your family strolling up
to the gate show now clearly our
soldiers they're sitting ducks our
flights in and out are at risk of being
shot down there is no safe passage
whatsoever this is an unmitigated
foreign policy disaster total
humiliation for the united states on the
world stage and the saddest part of all
of it is every single bit of this was
preventable easily preventable six days
ago joe biden vowed any attack on our
forces or disruption of our operations
at the airport will be met with a swift
and forceful response but today during
what i can only describe as a
at times incoherent bizarre mumbling
bumbling rambling speech joe biden he
presented no plan of action whatsoever
no strategy no change in strategy no
extra military support the taliban
deadline of next tuesday apparently
remains in place and biden all but
acknowledged americans our fellow
citizens our friends and our neighbors
will be left behind enemy lines hostages
to the whims of terrorists an
unconscionable disaster one of the
biggest foreign policy debacles ever in
american history at one point during the
speech joe actually bragged about being
a student of history and lectured all of
us about why we just need to accept that
some people will just be left behind i'm
having a hard time with this
what do you say to the afghans who
helped troops
who may not be able to get out by august
31st
we're going to continue to try to get
you out it matters look
i know of no conflict
as a student of history
no conflict
where when a war was ending
one side was able to guarantee that
everyone
they wanted to be extracted from that
country
would get out
mark my words we are about to witness an
international hostage situation on a
massive scale and in the meantime
everyone inside that airport everyone
outside the airport all are in imminent
danger but it's not totally clear that
joe biden comprehends any of this at
best to be charitable i guess one can
say he's incredibly stupid at worst he
is in a full-scale cognitive decline
frankly all day today i sat in horror he
looked like a deer in the headlights and
completely and utterly clueless and now
someone other than joe biden appears to
be calling the shots inside the white
house take a look at this
ladies and gentlemen they gave me a list
here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
wow i've been instructed okay joe can
you tell us who's instructing you on
what questions to take you're the
president of the united states of
america but in a very rare move biden
did ultimately take an unscripted
question from our very own peter ducey
let's just say a little bit more than
joe was ready for or could handle then
he tried to be the questioner take a
look
you said the buck stops with you
do you bear any responsibility
for the way that things have unfolded in
the last two weeks i bear responsibility
for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of
that afghanistan
i think
they have an issue
that
people
are like to get hurt
some as we've seen gotten killed
and that it is messy
to pull out yes i do because look at it
this way folks and i'm gonna i have
another meaning for real
but
imagine
where we'd be
if i had indicated
on may the first
i was not going to renegotiate
a
evacuation date
we were going to stay there
this is what a week of frail and a
cognitively compromised presidency looks
like we tried to warn you people are
dying our allies have lost faith our
enemies are completely emboldened
tonight hostile regimes are salivating
joe biden doesn't even seem to grasp
what's happening in fact over the past
few weeks he essentially bragged that
afghanistan's withdrawal was going great
shinsaki said it's going perfectly he
planned for every contingency after all
remember this
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history so and that is
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out
so no i would not say that is anything
but a success we were clear-eyed about
the risk
we plan for every contingency we have
control of the airport now still a lot
of pandemonium outside the airport well
there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now
thanks to the way in which we have
managed our withdrawal no one
no one us forces or any forces have uh
have been lost
conducting our drawdown differently
would have certainly come with a
increased risk of safety to our
personnel to me
those risks were unacceptable
this is how you define success why
didn't you do it in april in may in june
when we not when we saw we witnessed we
watched the taliban taking over larger
and larger portions of afghanistan on
their way to kabul why didn't you
extract every american and every ally
and all of our military equipment the 83
billion you left behind why didn't you
plan logistically to do that before they
took control of kabul the highest daily
number of american deaths in over a
decade in afghanistan today all because
of biden's horrible plan and of course
he stayed on vacation he just pulled the
troops out during the fighting season
abandoned bagram airfield ignored the
taliban's rapid advance in april in may
in june july and just apparently hope
for the best now an unknown number of
americans are still trapped in
afghanistan behind enemy lines they are
screwed they still have no idea how many
americans are trapped so are their
families so are their friends and so are
our allies and according to a report
from politico someone in the bite
administration
actually gave the taliban get this a
list of names of american citizens green
card holders and afghan allies that the
taliban is not allowing any entry to the
airport to to grant entry into the
militant controlled outer perimeter of
the city's airport one defense official
telling politico quote basically they
just put all those afghans on a kill
list joe biden claims he doesn't trust
the taliban just he gave them a list of
people who worked with the united states
or a more accurate description he's
likely signed their death certificates
on top of all the computer programs with
every name of every afghan that ever
helped us including biometrics which
will help identify these people while
also giving the the taliban the power to
secure the perimeter of the airport with
their notorious checkpoints still no
answer as to why they did not evacuate
every american and ally and the 83
billion dollars in military equipment
including the 208
blackhawk helicopters and aircraft that
we left behind and the sad truth is joe
biden's cowardice stupidity has forced
the most powerful nation on earth with
the mightiest military on earth into a
corner he's ignored dozens of important
warnings he's rejected advice from those
on the ground sources telling us on this
program this is not and was not in any
way an intelligence failure the cia they
pulled their people out weeks ago they
warned joe biden in no uncertain terms
daily and they've been warning him for
months and he never listened and now
he's too weak too spineless to fight
back or even a justice plan send in more
military to help ensure that we extract
every american and leave no american
behind joe biden ultimately now as of
today has blood on his hands his actions
frankly are unforgivable his
administration they cannot be trusted
and i fear frankly and i pray that god
i'm wrong the worst is yet to come joe
biden has been and he remains mia
president trump will join us in a few
moments we'll get his take on this
disaster and how he would have prevented
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else